just introduce yourself and tell me who
I'm speaking to I'm Gary Harris from
dfla and what does dfla mean for
American viewers that might not okay
Democratic football Lads Alliance and
why are we here today so we're here
today because we're we're marching and
protesting against all the the wrongs
that our establishment are putting
against our people and particularly The
Grooming gangs The Grooming gangs is one
of the subjects that we we are very
unhappy about absolutely there's rape
gangs there's pedophilia within our
establishment we've got the the
treatment of our soldiers you know
recently we've just had the one which is
um the poor ladders with Tommy you know
disgraceful these Lads go out and give
their lives for us so we're not happy
about that so we're here against the
injustices of the people of this country
there's a particular phenomenon in the
other whatever Muslims have settled
particularly the Pakistani Muslims rape
gangs are prevalent whatever they say so
that's a cultural thing yeah yeah yeah
obviously we've got a number of towns
and we've been to South have been to
Rochdale where we've protested and and
demonstrated Against The Grooming gangs
in them two towns also here today that
there's a massive counter demonstration
against well it's so weird but you know
what I mean but they can't turn up
everywhere you go they appear so why do
these people support those how can they
support right I don't know let's be one
thing though right we accept we got rape
in all communities paid affiliate in all
communities at every level of our
establishment we've got the grooming
gangs we've got the the rape gangs as
well that raped the women right so they
Mark women drag them in the pub we go
outside the rape gangs are waiting for
them yeah we've got a group here today
called Justice for the women and
children that were formed in the
northeast of the country in Sunderland
who protest strongly about all forms of
rape so these people turn up call us
racist Nazis for one in better for our
children to stop our children being
raped it's a disgrace so I always say
that um the word the word racist it's
like the left it's by Agra
small communities I've Got Friends of
all colors we're not racist we just
don't want our children being raped but
that's that's their go-to phrase you're
a racist to shut you down
they've used it so much and would you
hook their shoes today during government
pay any attention well we're putting a
letter in 10 Downing Street at R3 we've
had granted an appointment the the media
are beginning to look at us a little bit
Gerald Batten from ukip is 100 behind us
and raising this subject he's the only
politician in this country with the
bolts to do that
I'm